[Music]  foreign  s came pouring over the 38th parallel  This Is War and we're up  we know this day might come it doesn't  make it any easier  [Music]  running officer called you one of the  best Pilots he's ever seen  it must be hard being the Naval aviator  it's the toughest job there is Jim  thinks that you'd be in a squadron with  a colored Aviator  I can't take it how many times people  have told me to give up quit  that I even  that's why you can't always do what  you're told  what do you want me to do just be  modeling math  [Applause]  Jesse  just remember you belong down here with  us too okay  I need everyone sharp and ready those  boys are Holding On by their fingernails  we bring everyone  home ready  and then what you fighting for  [Applause]  the show off that was pretty good it's  good  [Music]